tu feras encore que je dégage mal et non
non non non non il commença jeu rapide
la gauche j'ai l'impression que si man
show oui oui oui oui oui et non il
trotte 40 ans c'est parce que c'est
dimanche sincères regrets ont fait
jusqu'ici parce que tu vas la paix tout
l'espace jeunes quand on a beau râler la
baraque quand on n'est pas en train de
nous
allez
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi compare pas pour toulon tu vas
un scrutin trop juste ça finira par
faire du village en avant toujours été
aussi fatalité fatalisme si tu veux le
résultat est le même
pourquoi tu l'as à la corde on n'est pas
heureux tous les deux a tant déçu
t'aimes pas notre vie mais un peu revue
ou bien je me suis habitué
coq hardi apparaît plutôt comme un
parfait on se dispute mais au lit on
s'explique
et sur leur ailier hausse comprend alors
alors rien j'en ai assez dit je
m'applique si tu saisis jeu mass fixie à
toulon il ya de l'air puisqu'il ya la
mer tu respires à mieux lors des
mondiaux à ça sentira le bouhris allons
à l'étranger outre la n'y avait pas
cette idée alors ça sera partout pareil
j'ai besoin de changer l'atmosphère est
bonne atmosphère cette fois c'est la
première fois qu'on prête atmosphère ici
la mosquée bien drôle d'homme l'aide des
petits sons du milieu sans emmener
makiko la photo ce qu'ils ont été on
devra les vider atmosphère atmosphère
atmosphère jusqu'à ce que sera assis
tout seul et la varenne ne pas gâcher ma
l'atmosphère
vous direz ce que vous voudrez vous
chers cousins il est fort regrettable
que margaret ne soit pas le canard
l'admira le canard aux aurores et je
suis une aile et puis une cuisse
où est-elle exactement cette chaire
magar accès dit la campagne au loin d'un
pas très loin d'ici
j'ai des amis et les amis
nous sommes des amis que nous
connaissons il ya longtemps que celle
d'ivan versanne est à votre service et
vao mais certainement cher cousin est
ici depuis 15 ans noah a non je
confondais avec la cuisinière à madame
penchard poussins vous ne prenez pas
étrange que votre femme est précisément
choisi le jour où je vis a dit les dons
pour ça m'a l'air en voyage elle a dû
partir brusquement pour un cas de
rougeole comprendre qu'à subite
le premier vous m'avez dit qu'elle était
parti chez des amis justement cdc des
habitants la rougeole à un certain
niveau
vous marque il exactement ses amis qui
ont la rougeole merci exactement vous me
demandez si recousu où il demeure
exactement là c'est bien simple et il
demeure exactement 1 dans les environs
de brighton je crois vous croyez qu'un
cousin
bizarre bizarre qu'est-ce qu'il a le
couteau
comment vous vous regardez votre côté
vous dit bizarre bizarre lors je croyais
que moi j'ai dit bizarre bizarre comme
c'est étrange
pourquoi les d'ibiza bizarre je vous
assure cher cousin que vous avez dit
bizarre bizarre
moi j'ai dit bizarre comme c'est bizarre
[Musique]
attention le bouchon plus
à
si bon
éprise de voyage est déjà fini
ce serait tellement beau ions pur et
parfait comme ça sur la mer et les deux
les deux équipes ça me fait penser que
[Musique]
oui j'en ai en parlant à ce jour les
petites photos d'identité comme quoi
intense pause
[Musique]
et les tueries mais il a pas l'habitude
c'est drôle de fille paris c'est vrai
les quatre regarde et écoute et puis tu
pleures allait bien patrick cartographie
avec leur fils en garde
[Musique]
enfin non j'ai envie de gagner ouais
c'est bien avec moi vous pouvez pas
savoir comme jeudi a constitué la spire
je suis vivant ça va être comme ça
continue pour tout ce que tu dis ça
tiens prends les étudierai salle autre
que moi je trouve ça idiot mais tu veux
à 10 comme ça à moi bah c'est marrant ça
me plaît
tu as beau
forcément
oui
[Musique]
et
pour hp
[Musique]
c'est vous le tambour de ville oui
monsieur
appelez moi docteur un bon témoin oui
doctor who nos docteurs et quand vous
avez l'occasion de parler de maudore ne
manquait jamais de vous exprimer ainsi
le docteur a dit le docteur a fait j'y
attache de l'importance
quand vous parlez entre vous dis docteur
pape allait de quels termes vous
servez-vous au balo lyon grenoble le bo
bien fort ce n'est pas ce que je vous
demande vous disiez vous le docteur en
ont nous disions monsieur par palais où
le médecin ou encore ravachol c'est
pourquoi russell un surnom qui l'avait
j'ai jamais su pourquoi et vous ne jugez
pas très fort bon pour moi était un
effort mais pour d'autres types avec
nantes
quand on a les loueurs qui trouvaient
pas et qu'elle signerait pas ce que vous
aviez leur fusion d'ici vous le voyez
j'ai eu envie ils ont bravé rien du tout
vous soucier de ma mon habillement au
mas et vous et vous d'un peu d'argent
[Musique]
épuisée bessette parler d'autre chose
mon honneur n'est par exemple de son
automobile
comme si on venait pour ça et puis vous
indiquez bien le maître de quatre sous
quelquefois ils sympathisent n o
n'avez vous pas si bien que les gens qui
paient 8 francs pour une consultation
c'est le protocole indique admettent de
gansu et le plus bête il a besoin du
médecin bulgares moby ce que vous
m'appreniez me fait réellement la peine
mais je vous ai appelés pour un
renseignement ne quel prix le monde y
est vous au docteur papa l'est quand ils
vous changez d'une annonce même je n'ai
jamais d'une annonce
qu'est-ce qui vous me dites depuis 30
ans qu'ils étaient là mais pas une seule
annonce en trente ans je le gêne on
voulait avoir oublié mais non je ne suis
pas vous croire
bref quels sont vos tarifs offrant le
petit tour 500 grands tours ah ça vous
parlez de tête seul mais il ya du
travail
d'ailleurs moi je conseille à monsieur
le docteur ma part je conseille au
docteur sinon les voies deux fronts près
je prends mon tour je prends un grand
tour et vous êtes disponible ce matin on
met tout de suite si vous voulez voici
donc le texte de la lance
je suis habitué aux écritures mais je
préférais vous me disiez une première
fois le docteur knock successeur du
docteur par palais présente ses
compliments à la population de la ville
et du canton de saint maurice est à
l'honneur de lui faire connaître que
dans un esprit philanthropique ion
philanthropiques et ouais
et pour enrayer les progrès inquiétant
des maladies de toutes sortes qui
envahissent depuis quelques années nos
régions si salubre autrefois hausse
assez rudement les fruits il donnera
tous les lundis matins de 9h30 à 11h30
une consultation entièrement gratuite
réservée aux habitants du canton bassa
c'est une belle idée avoue trouver un
sujet qui sera précisée c'est ludique
bienfaiteurs mais on sait qu'on est
lundi oui mais si je fais mon annonce ce
matin et va vous en arrivez dans cinq
minutes
un site web et vous savez peut-être pas
que lundi c'est le jour du marché mais
mais la moitié du canton et l'âme
mon discours va tomber dans tout ce
monde mais ça aurait pu donner de la
tête
je tâcherai de me débrouiller mais il ya
encore ceux ci c'est que c'est le lundi
vous aviez le plus de chances d'avoir
les pignons monsieur parle pas mais on
savait que le jour là alors si vous
voulez sauver gratis
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais vous
comprenez mon ami vous comprenez ce que
je veux avant tout c'est que les gens se
soignent si je voulais gagner de
l'argent c'est à paris que je
m'installerai ou à new york où elle va
nous a aimés lois tue on se soit une
pince et on veut pas écouter on semaine
trop durement quand le mal vous tient à
wroclaw autres reviennent des animaux
sains
donc je concevais mon avis et roman noir
roman dit on fait un maire je pourrais
pas revenir tout à l'heure et ollon
j'arriverai trop tard est-ce que ça
serait un effet de votre bonté de me
donner ma consultation maintenant oui
mais les débuts sont j'ai rendez vous
avec monsieur bernard l'instituteur et
avec monsieur le pharmacien mousquet il
faut que je les reçoivent
avant que les gens n'arrivent de quoi
ces frais vous attendez que j'aime les 6
et ben voilà
quand j'ai dîné oui eh bien il ya des
fois je sens comme une espèce de
démangeaisons ici rens ça me chatouille
ou même plus tôt vous ça vous détruit
attention attention ne confondons pas
est ce que ça vous chatouille ou est-ce
que ça vous gratouille pas ça me
chatouille mais ça me fera du bien aussi
désigné mois exactement la loi aubry j
aï si oui et oui sa part ici et là hop
tête mal à prendre le les deux entre
juste entrée qu est ce que ça ne serait
pas plutôt un rien à gauche largement
doit elle me semble bien fait et ça vous
fait mal quand jean en france mon doigt
a oui on dirait que ça me fait mal à à à
est ce que ça ne vous gratuits pas
davantage quand vous allez manger de la
tête de veau à la vinaigrette aux gens
meurent jamais au même semble bien si
j'en mangeais oui eh ben fectivement ça
me gratte où il est plus à très
important très important quel âge avez
vous ben 51 dans mes 50 de plus près de
51 52 au plus près de 59 ans l'âge
aidant les panneaux van aelst mon ami
faites votre travail aujourd'hui comme
d'habitude ce soir couche fou de bonheur
demain matin garder le lit je passerais
vous voir pour vous mes visites seront
gratuites mais ne le dites pas n'est ce
pas c'est une faveur et trouvons ne
devrait annoncer demain parce que j'ai
ce n'est peut être pas encore très grave
il était temps de vous soigner vous
soumet alors non je seek défense absolue
chick et vous aimez 20 ans boire
raisonnablement plus une goutte de vin
vous êtes se marier pour le sage est
totale
de ce côté là et ont mangé et bien
aujourd'hui comme vous travaillez prenez
un peu de potage demain nous en
viendrons à des restrictions plus
sérieuse pour l'instant tenez vous en à
ce que je vous ai dit croyez pas que ce
serait bien de me coucher tout de suite
je me sens réellement pas mon instinct
de vous en bien gardez vous en bien dans
votre cas il est mauvais d'aller se
mettre au lit entre le lever et le
coucher du soleil
oui faites vous annonce comme si de rien
n'était et attendait tranquillement
jusqu'à soir ouais ben qu'est-ce que
vous arrive au revoir un gel mariette
[Musique]
j'en mange pierre fou soit comment ah
oui bien françois frey parce que j'aime
à déranger tant de noms que parfois je
me perds m'amène puéril précaution
d'ailleurs leur police et si mal fait
ce n'est pas comme la mienne je sais
beaucoup de choses moi par exemple quand
vous êtes revenu de suite je lis
oui j'ai su où vous viviez et avec qui
mon âge vous vous leviez on peut rien
cacher je sais aussi qu'on l'a mise en
cage mon âge mon boulanger dans la plus
belle cage de bain ont d'ailleurs je ne
jette pas la pierre j'ai moi aussi
beaucoup le cul en prison ces derniers
temps et en province encore qu'on a pas
l'ombre d'un sourire
pourtant je vous amuse autrefois allez
vous perdez votre getty ou bien et louis
désagréablement surprise de leur roi non
au contraire même cela me fait plaisir
oui ça me rappelle toute une époque
oui des années faciles mais je vous
recevrai cette attention mon ange il
n'est pas bon de regarder en arrière on
se retourne sur son passé ou sautent à
la figure comme un chantage est tout de
même j'ai eu la chance d'être heureuse
magritte
autrefois nous dit pas de bêtise
autrefois et maintenant séparé de temps
à jean ferrat devenait vraiment et
l'homme blanc votre ami le funambule
royaux qui souhaiterait lui aussi quand
je pense que j'ai eu l'idée saugrenue de
lit tu es le fils qu'elle cocasserie
n'est ce pas autant tirer sur un courant
des dirigeants sur un rayon de lune et
l'autre oui frédéric filloux à vous
maintenant j'ai passé aussi je suivais
vallet loire j'avais trouvé un un
amusant prétexte peut-on savoir et bien
sûr je me suis dit voilà de quoi je ne
connais pas je les mallettes d'argent il
pas refusé et il voulait donner
oui pébereau sommes encore ce stupéfiant
faillit bien qu'il ya tout de même des
gens désintéressés neige des acteurs ne
sont pas des gens c'est tout le monde et
personne à la fois les acteurs des gens
les gens du monde ça c'est des gens
lepointe edouard de montrer par exemple
un des hommes les plus brillants les
plus riches de france
vous avez changé pierre-françois mois ou
et autrefois on parlait surtout de jouer
rarement des autres mois plus tôt ce que
vous êtes devenu
je suis devenue célèbre oui j'ai réussi
quelques méfaits sirotant tissant le
long de la sner à défrayer plus d'une
fois la chronique judiciaire lacenaire
que la police recherche aujourd'hui en
province alors qu'il est là avec son
ange gardien dans sa bonne ville de
bagdad
oui ça commence mais elle a un truc
sinon j'aurais tout de même procuré une
éclatante réussite littéraire celui
compte en france a bondi n'est ce pas
que le compte de montrer s'intéresse
beaucoup aux harkis c'est un très
généreux mécènes ça me ferait plaisir de
le voir et que c'est utile -
assurez-vous je lui mentais rien
j'aimerais connaître cet homme qui a
posé la main froide de la richesse sur
la planche épaules de mon ange gardien
rassurez-vous mon invité sans condition
je suis libre peut-être c'est bien ce
qui me chagrine
vous pouvez pas savoir 40 ans bien
sonnés de vous avoir retrouvé et
surtout vous n'ayez pas changé j'aurais
tellement préféré vous voir abîmé soum
unités sucre utilisée par l'argent comme
ça j'aurais pu continuer à vivre avec
une bonne petite conscience tranquille
avec la pêche dès que j'ai gâché mon
pauvre pierre françois vous trouvez je
suis un monstre n'est ce pas peut-être
mais vous n'êtes on sait hélas
[Musique]
bonjour 1
il voulait pas s'avancer encore même que
ces jeunes génies vous a fait ce costume
donnez-moi son adresse que j'ai couvre
feu c'est à dire c'est un tout petit
tailleur fixe je voudrais bien
volontiers son adresse seulement ça nous
servira à rien parce que ce costume
c'est moi qu'il est conçu et dessiné il
en faut qu'il grandisse inattendu est
que c'est dommage pourquoi c'est dommage
oh que c'est dommage qu'un homme comme
lui à cause de considérations familiales
ou sociales ne puisse la fête du cinéma
il est naturellement chacun un bien peut
pas la voir faire du cinéma en qualité
de quoi on en qualité d'acteur aux
acteurs le physique joue un rôle
important
l'élégance compte aussi vous savez bon
de côté le principal c'est le sex-appeal
à ça et je peux dire qu'il a une voix
tout à fait sex-appeal quoiqu'il soit
ridicule à dire ces choses là
moi il me semble que j'allais un peu
mais il faudrait que je le cultive des
charmants modestie non monsieur je suis
pas modeste je l'écoutais mais du jour
où j'ai décidé de devenir un artiste
j'ai sacrifié la modestie alors
sérieusement songé à faire du cinéma jeu
c'est à dire que non seulement ce sont
mes jean rède j'en suis malade j'en
crève cinéma monsieur mais c'est ma
passion pour jouer même un petit rôle je
sois n'importe quoi je le jouerai même
gratuitement le premier bien entendu mes
enfants j'ai eu l'idée et je m'étonne
qu'aucun de vous ne les tue avant moi
quelle idée le schpountz le schpountz
c'est lui mais qu'est ce que c'est que
le spawn
le spoon monsieur le schpountz c'est un
rôle extraordinaire dans un film
extraordinaire
depuis cinq ans on n'a trouvé aucun
artiste pour l'incarner au cas où on a
essayé toutes les plus grandes vedettes
tout tout tout les plus grands noms de
l'écran aucun n'a plus de l'internet
c'est greta garbo un homme vous voir des
comptes
monsieur vous m'effrayé un peu oui il
faut pas s'emballer
moi il me semble que dans la vie
monsieur est un chemin semé à l'écran il
serait encore beaucoup plus tout ça fait
avoir le rhône on s'amuse à mes enfants
et moi je donne mon avis ça il est bien
évident serait subordonnée à des essais
pour tromper ah oui mais alors ces
essais qui sont la base de tout quand
les fait-on bah moi je peux tout de
suite faire l'essai de son si vous
voulez est ce que vous savez quelque
chose par coeur une chanson mais je ne
veux pas vous dire un poème ou chanter
une chanson ce serait une piste parce
que si le poème est beau ou pourriez
attribué le mérite aux résidents j'ai
donc vous proposer autre chose qui sera
beaucoup plus concluants mais ce qu'il
est très intéressant et les flots dont
parlait merci oui ce que je vous propose
ce monsieur c'est vous récitez l'article
du code civil le plus court et le plus
net
je dirais presque le plus tranchant
c'est celui ci tous condamnés à mort aux
rats la tête tranchée non c'est pas gai
c'est pas gai non mais ça peut le
devenir
je prétends messieurs devant votre
accueil amical vous donner une
démonstration complète de même modeste
mérite je vais avec cette simple phrase
vous inspirer des sentiments les plus
divers il sera dans l'express quelques
il doit avoir comme expression ne jouais
pas l'avant ce monsieur
attendez c'est vrai oui absolument
et bien alors je commence voilà
[Musique]
tous condamnés à mort aux rats la tête
tranchée
c'est inouï à la pitié tout combat les
amants aura la tête tranchée
interrogatif attire mais tous condamnés
à mort aux rats la tête tranchée tous
condamnés à mort ou à la tête tranchée
et se met à penser ça vous branche
animation garder l'expression voilà
comique
[Musique]
[Rires]
je vous amène mon pote s'appelle georges
jo pour les dames vous pouvez ça lui on
est ensemble encore exempt pendant cinq
ans en raison bien se présente bonsoir
la migraine la migraine cas jamais soit
tu vois ce que je veux dire
je n'écoute pas joli joli c'est celui-là
c'est roland belle gueule
double de leychert raid on met bas le
tibet six mois les bourreaux date car on
va quand même ce soir
[Musique]
quand vous étiez pas abattu quand ça
fait combien suivant ce domaine
[Musique]
et ce qui fait ton pote je lui ai
repensé
monsieur travaille pour mon gars tu dois
voir soit un charpentier vous rendez
compte à peu près 30 à sion il est vrai
que j'avais arrêté boulanger longtemps
bien une celle d'un fils charpentier la
meilleure grâce aux de belleville et
demi
oui
[Musique]
histoire aux langes
les gentils on veut faire plaisir cette
idée
fm
à qui ça
vous
et dedans il se défend mon petit peuple
on se défend même très bien
[Musique]
je
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
achèvement voix de madame
alors merci monde et j'ai une chaîne
sans rater pas galant mon pote à marie
question dit
[Musique]
c'est un geste fort envers les cia
comment tu t'appelles déjà alors mon
gars pourquoi cet intérêt ce pauvre long
[Musique]
et là monsieur
excusez moi mais on attend et on
parvient comme ça mon petit gars est pas
gentil brutalement sud
alors ça va tu vois aller fâché
[Musique]
tombeur de la vasque joueurs art je
t'accompagne il est occupante il ya peu
peur il est parti de rien pour meinau
il est garant géant l'adresse alors en
vacances
[Musique]
à voir
bouleversée mademoiselle
et
s'agace
je
[Musique]
les lunettes c'est pas fini tu sais
connaissez cette heure là oh non plus et
pourtant pour les 120 connaît un rayon
moi je vous ai déjà entendu mais où et
quand
[Musique]
heureusement c'est toujours triste de
licences ont de l'amour n'est pas
toujours dire est ce parce que les gens
ne savent pas le père ou qu'ils font
semblant
pourquoi tu dessines et un chinois un
chinois citoyens dont deux chinois
et c'est vrai un chinois est chez moi ça
c'est formidable je me rappelle bien
entendu la chanson c'était 1,38 à san
francisco encina tôt c'est beau c'est
francis taulan oui c'est un mot porc
j'ai bien failli laisser mes droits
fiscaux un tuba garrigue
comme dit que les bananes enfin c'était
pas monnaie le destin le destin de
gestas et moi un royaume et moi je suis
ne peut nous y perdons napoléon et est
un homme comme les autres il est ni la
mort de son père et il est ma télé
c'était nécessaire s'il n'était pas mort
à sainte hélène peut-être qu'il n'aurait
pas vu le jour ajaccio
tout s'enchaîne il n'y a rien
d'extraordinaire
ou plutôt si il n'y a que les choses se
trament ère l'homme s'habitue assez
chaudes par exemple le soleil ils
trouvent ça naturel le soleil ça ne
m'étonne pas mais si on lui montre un
veau à deux têtes ça l'inquiète et
pourtant un veau un simple coup de tous
les jours avec une seule pièce que nous
aimons c'est bien étrange jean
inexplicable contenu riche et quand je
dis un mot je pourrais aussi bien durant
dans vos menaces quel mystère à not work
j'ai connu des gens quand ils
entendaient le matin le cryptage il
grelottait littéraire ça leur donnait la
chair de poule
quelle histoire et l'histoire et
pourtant chacun son histoire toit où les
jeunes comme les autres
tu ne sais pas comment elle finira t-on
histoire j'assume c'est une surprise oui
une surprise ce qui pour quoi que mais
ici ce soir
[Musique]
jetez vos dîners non donnez moi une
finale où on ne sait jamais l'être qu'au
territoire de manière par ici il insiste
si tu veux savoir
je suis venu ici parce que j'avais
rendez vous et pas plus tard que ce soit
avec qui avec une belle fille la plus
belle fille du monde tentant la plus
belle pourquoi pas
[Musique]
est ce que vous regardez d'échanger des
douze caisses qu'il a les deux bouts
c'est par la fenêtre qu'est-ce qui se
passe
il est à sa fenêtre mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe baggio juin qu'est ce que vous
attendez attendez cochon à l assassin
reste intéressant un assassin juillet la
cession mais oui je suis agacé mais les
attaques ont des rues d'hénin pas tous
battus mardi était un petit peu
seulement au dessus en douceur alors ça
serait pas si comme la salle s'étendent
dans le foot et le corps préfectoral et
vous en cachez vous vous direz ça notre
journal se serait imprimée tous remplis
mais tous ont dit vous lirez débit vous
le croirez parce que dans les journaux
raconte tout ils sont bien renseignés
journaux à la faute et qu'allez vous
allez frapper froid dépit des vous mais
chez moi seul tous attendent et je
[Musique]
fatigue et laissez-moi soir
et j'ai pu conscience j'ai fini délit
vous entendez françois rachline pas ça
sert à rien ya les gens qui ont peut
déjà ils ne sont pas mal et sans envers
après est dit dans les gars ya une place
à prendre
une bonne pratique place un bon petit
boulot avec des heures supplémentaires
alors allez-y qu'est ce que vous
attendez
en valeur la tout un petit bonheur ajoie
vivre sortir ça s'arrangerait quoi
françois qu'elle reçoit ya la petite
france mais ce n'est pas très pris un
petit reçoit du parent ne paraissait
mois futé voit l'appel et visant tout et
voit la paix en soi reconnaît très bon
dieu ne pas se faire avoir
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on attend
bien des hommes
[Applaudissements]
et leur éthique
lina baril ces grands jours je vais en
80 et ronfler que ce que ça fait quinze
ans par mon fils j'ai veillé toute la
nuit
il montera pas c'est moi qui suis sur
mon travail on sait très bien qu'ils
reviennent avec leurs tares qui là
qu'est ce que j'y passerais tu ne m'as
pas vrai je te jure je voudrais que
parfois de malheurs comme à pépé en être
le cas par change d'époque
oui je prends ça ma jeunesse je regarde
ma vieille photo et je me dis que je
suis devant une glace permet un de mes
anciens disques du temps vous avez de
grandes succès à la scala boulevard de
strasbourg
c'est pareil c'est en scène dans un
décor champêtre avec un projet de rouge
braqués sur mon visage parle et je
chantais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
y en a qui vous phare de la mérite
je sens la vision de jeu c'est
magnifique c'est notre pari n'est rien
au fait ça c'est vraiment la responsable
de cette affaire en ce moment je suis le
monstre accusant un ancien jardin de la
famille les gars et les prescrits cette
émigration sert nasri je dirais 30 à
vous écrire mon contrat
mon bistrot du coin télé joue pour nous
c'était dimanche
ensuite ils les amis ou nos pas nous
souhaitons tous nos voeux bal musette
leur joie au son accord léo vous
soutenir prazuck
ah on pouvait même sens jacques vabre on
de fatigue et dites moi vous avez peur
de mourir tout de même aux non pas moi à
vous mais qui alors en fait c'est moi et
ne saurait qu'on fait c'est moi qu'on
fait c'est moi ça c'est facile à dire
vous croyez qu'on fait sa connaissance
non j'ai pas ce qu'il me faut est ce
qu'il vous faut
il nous faut un confessionnal ou tout au
moins le gris gris il faut pas qu'elle
se voit tous les deux pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi toujours des questions je ne
demande pas moi qui suis moi je suppose
c'est parce qu'il faut pas qu'on sache à
qui on a affaire
vous avez bien c'est à - vous avez à
faire mais dès qu'il aura la grille je
ne saurais plus mais dit ça a l'air
d'aller beaucoup mieux fétiche - dirella
j'adhère je pense que ça suffira
vous voilà bien une chrétienne tout d'un
coup en tout cas il ya un péché que vous
avez fait c'est d'avoir voulu jeter un
peu pauvre prêtres dans la tempête
si c'est ça qui vous tourmentent
n'aggravez pas à votre faute en du
retard dans son souper merci
j'espère que le bon dieu s'en contentera
et alors
c'est moi d'abord mon père c'est vrai à
ce qu'ils racontent les prêtres jamais
il répète que la radio conditions
écoutez ma fille depuis comme ils en
comptent se confesse dieu sait si ça me
fait dépêcher aux mineurs jamais le
secret de la confession a été violée
saint-anselme cdc a acheté la langue
avec des tenailles rougis au feu plutôt
que de révéler une chance qui lui
avaient été confiées
et pourtant c'est une chose sans
importance comment laisser le sait pas
comme tu as eyed peas en somme c'est
pire encore on lui a coupé assez mon
père je vous crois mais vous vous
laisseriez h et la langue aux gens
n'auraient aucun mérite vous savez parce
que tout ce qui rentre pas cette oreille
samba par l'autre et entre les deux
oreilles ça ne reste pas un tout autre
peut aussi tôt que le pénitent le dos
tourné
cette envolée c'est une grâce que le bon
dieu nous fait prendre au mans vous
savez avec le camp nous raconte dit
votre convient d or je n'en avais plus
alors commencez votre confession depuis
20 ans au ps vous n'êtes pas confessé
depuis 20 ans
non mon père ça va être marrant fait ça
va être plus long encore depuis vingt
ans mon père que nous sommes établis
dans cette auberge de mon mari et moi
faut vous dire que nous étions marchands
forains et puis un jour mon mari a eu
envie cotes fixes c'est alors qu'on
s'est installé ici
moi ça me tenait bien un peu je disais
martin ce n'est pas bien pensants mais
il me répondait n'inquiète pas mariée
ici
ici il y aura pas de morte saison alors
je lui disais mais des clients il y en
aura pas beaucoup il me disait on n'aura
peut-être pas beaucoup mais on les
regardera j'avais pas encore compris ce
qu'il voulait dire
moi non plus attendez quand il disait ça
parce qu'il aimait bien à rire dans le
temps et puis aux premiers voyageurs
j'ai compris
c'est un gros marché d'intel avec son
cheval pour la garder longtemps le
cheval
le marchand aussi on l'a gardé il est
encore ici je me rappelle bien ou parce
que c'était le premier dans le jardin
sous le châtaignier soja venir dans la
terrine à la terre puisqu'il était mort
non ça nous fera comprendre mes clients
le second c'était à parisien un bon
garçon un célibataire ça va aller mieux
oui breux parce que personne ne les
pleurs les célibataires
parce qu'il est mort lui aussi très vite
vous n'avez pas de chance il n'a pas
beaucoup souffert celui là est le 3e il
a encore moins souffert
mon mari s'était fait la main à rentrer
mari s'était fait la main et oui il cdc
je commence à vous comprendre oui qu'est
ce que vous voulez chez nous c'est si
facile
vous avez bien vu l'escalier avec le
petit renfoncement vous mettez pas eu ce
coup force et c'est là que ça se passait
les trois premiers oui parce qu'elle
aille dont on les compte plus or on les
compte plus le voyant pas plus de 10 mon
père presque vannes 6 et d'examens quoi
30 à copenhague posions mon père je vous
ai dit depuis 20 ans alors tant pis ça
ne ferait même pas 2 par an
et qu'est-ce que ses deux parents est
d'abord une immense
alors comme bien si vous voulez le
savoir ce soir c'était le 102e ah bon je
suis tombé je vais vous l'expliquer mon
père dans une auberge want it all ondes
c'est un résultat tout autour et encore
ils ne sont pas tous au tollé le dernier
vous pouvez le voir ou par la fenêtre
moitié alors rien du tout et où ça d'un
bonhomme de neige
la dame peu de temps mais il n'est pas
plus mal d'ailleurs poussé qui pourrait
être dans le vent d'un cochon quoi vous
donner les chrétiens à manger aux
cochons fait il les mange bien et vont
leur manger du cochon
je vous dirais que moi je n'aime pas
tant que ça le cochon il rejoint du
cochon tant mieux c'est
ça fait boire
allez allez allez je te dis qu'ils
étaient à deux voitures ils m'avaient
bandé les yeux mais quand ils sont
arrivés j'ai entendu l'autre qui
continuaient de rouler
j'ai vous mon dieu pensez vous
cancun mieux que ça là on livre un
nouvel élan dans ce mondial
l effet le mot
rex
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'huile l'ont pas ratée
je fais point d'épouser tout de suite me
suis dit en tout cas c'est pas avec
celle là qu'on va pouvoir continuer
riton va chercher leur chariot vitesse
du capot
[Musique]
je
c'est pour toi si mais qu'est ce qu'il
fout
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est vers les plaines
[Musique]
l'académie des banlieues grises dit
mais m
quoi
[Musique]
et on se tire
ayrault
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
vous êtes sûr de lui absolument et en
plus je lui ai rien dit il ce ma peau
mais alors on est beau alors si vite
il est déjà tard on n'a pas de temps à
perdre c'est google buzz un tel
compliment c'est le joli travail
la colombie n'a pas eu à se plaindre
vous y connaissez j'aime beaucoup le
chapitre i je préfère dans le cochon moi
c'est la palette bompard entre son frère
et vous c'est pas la planète que vous
préférez
à propos et les a trouvés bull et
renault madame mariette il était pas
mauvais mais un petit peu trop frais
tout de même la palette avec un petit
air alsace tiens à propos de l'alsace
écoute on est ici pour travailler c'est
pas trop votre payer le coût il est
assez grand pour le faire oui mais il
n'y pensais pas on va servez-vous est
important
c'est la rue d'un paquet ce sont les
classes moi oui la rue poliveau quoi la
rue posez-vous bah quoi la bonne maladie
telle avait poliment et mérite peut-être
ils ont peut-être pas non non non non je
vous ai dit qu'on est précis et ce soir
c'est pas la porte à côté un scénario
dit qu on topic
vous m'avez dirait du temps moi je fais
pour une route du fer enfants deux
bornes en toi maintenant faire de la
question à faire c'est moi qui la parole
écoutée patron faudrait s'entendre si
c'est à mon art vous donnez combien
c'est bon je voudrais savoir plus oui
oui je demande pas l'aumône à pour mon
marx à 6 enfants par rome au bon soir
parce que c'est voulu profiter de la
situation en fuite et se taper en
question de la rue poliveau à la rue
lepic se farcir toutes les tendances et
paris avec par tous les flics les
poulets les prix et les souliers qu'on
use le tout aux pas de chasseurs en
pleine gloire ces kilomètres
oui parfois seulement de rien c'est bon
ils ont 400 francs home à ce prix là
chercher des crosses à moi je suis à
l'homme ça va chauffer un effort 450 x
900 francs pour les 2 1
dites-moi patron c'est bien le numéro 45
ici pourquoi me demander ça à bas pour
rien puisque je sais monsieur janvier 45
groupes au niveau paris 5e parce que
tranquille on parle sérieusement bon
entendus pour 900 monsieur janvier 45
rue poliveau pour moi je sais pas mille
francs patron fait comme s'il n'était
pas là vous me donnez 900 francs je
m'arrange avec lui
écoutez martin tant pis je viens me
franck vous allez me le camp
votre petite amie
donc c'est absolument sûr mais le 7 12
il sait pas ce qu'il dit oui il ya bien
deux c'est une classe pas si mal cet
article a d'abord il a des dents en or
après si ça implique pas un voisin ou un
faux suspens combien c'est pareil jamais
qu'à travailler rabin cieux janvier 45
rue au niveau maintenant c'est deux fois
c'est bon
mais il y avait 300 euros
[Musique]
le
mais vraiment pas quoi regarder moi
shagari cause premier choix wendel qui
c'était le moment de gâcher un incendie
non non non je voulais dire 3 mai 16 a
donné les raisons contre avoir la paix
ciel mon argent à bonbons motiver les
vous de ce qui vous regarde
il y avait tous ces péchés pour être
boucler vos valises abandonnées
maintenant vous avez vous prendre les
balles alors balles dans le corps mais
on va pas bientôt un pâton plomb
écoutez monsieur je vous en prie vous
débutez plus surtout son nom alors je
vais pas me taper tout cela mène à
l'époque chun à leurs amis anglais les
hommes
je ne lâcherai pas moi allez allez on y
va
dites moi monsieur janvier maintenant
vous les copains
si on me demande des renseignements sur
votre cochon d'où vient dit monsieur
cantine je m'en remets votre débit et
pour le reste est la grâce de dieu mais
pensez à ce que j'ai fait pour vous
tenez un petit paquet de gauloises à
pour le trajet ils entendent que deux
pilotes de ce gaz maintenant qu'est-ce
qui a encore rien mais c'est plus lourd
je ne pensais pas que yoann falloir 2000
francs de plus c'est sérieux
quant à cissé sérieux du tout
[Musique]
car à paris
mais pas fin on entend partout dans ce
cas sincèrement moi tu rien ça va
et maintenant les gens à les bouder sept
mois à les émois des boudins et moi et
vous n'allez dit qu'à 150 femmes dans
les visions de l'estany cette année
c'est bien c'est vous je me souviens pas
de ce cochon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à